we gave ralph a segment called beef of
the week and he's really hyper focused
on jd did you hear it jd it's like about
your weight
yeah i don't think he knows how much i
actually weigh he thinks i
i'm a lot fatter than i actually am did
you hear this robin
i have not heard it listen to this much
better than a
tweet it's time for us
there's a weird thing that goes on with
jd like howard talks about he's
overweight he's fat
right what is he how much does he weigh
i think he's like three high
like in jason's territory before jason
started losing weight you know and he's
and he's about three feet shorter so
anyway
he still eats badly right and he's got a
wife who's a trainer
and i i think her thing is fitness and i
just don't it's weird because
like jd is getting bigger i think his
wife is trying to kill him
she'll care she's a
well trainer is weird isn't it i i mean
you're cracking yourself up
like a joker like the joke yeah perhaps
turned into the joker he's like
and jd is fat
[Music]
that's beef i'm fat all of these rants
so far have been totally ridiculous
ralph how much do you think i weigh
well this week okay all right i'm gonna
take a guess if you don't mind
go ahead i'm gonna say it's a new
contest
tall are you by the way five nine
that means he's five do you need him to
stand up no i'm five nine
let me see your buddy stand up let me
take a look i can't this is like the
circus where they kiss your weight
oh it's not so bad i'm gonna say you're
2 23.
how am i doing i was going to say 225.
uh wrong i was 209 as of uh yesterday
so oh well there you go thank you yeah
you've left but like a month ago you
were a lot bigger
and you've been a lot bigger i don't
know this is not you know it's a
consistent problem with you
you know what about someone else take
off your shirt i want to see your tits
no that i'm not doing let's see your
underwear